brother from another follows this show
every day on nbc sports on peacock the
uh gents who
bat
stuff around and make you think and
laugh and have a good time are michael
holly and back here on the rich eisen
show michael smith how you doing michael
smith
i'm good
i'm good good to talk to y'all good to
talk to you too
i'm gonna start by answering your poll
question in a different way okay and the
question being being uh lsu or notre
dame uh which is the best job and for
for college
athletics i guess football go for it
michael go for it
uh lsu is the better job
notre dame's the more prestigious
program obviously
but here's my prediction
marcus freeman wins the national title
before brian kelly
that's really a hot take i really think
it's a stretch
okay now i do realize that every coach
since they already was three saban
uh miles and those are on all one
national champions and the last two
aren't good coaches okay
i i get all the recruiting advantages
and the
facilities and and the money and boost i
got it
you know
but
i see so much of uh and i've never met
this guy i've never met
marcus freeman
but
it feels real like
mike tomlin-ish
with regard to his meteoric rise
i mean people were pounding the table
for dude
and for and they entrusted that
prestigious program
to a 35 year old who was a defensive
coordinator in the power five
one year reminds me a little bit i hope
this isn't much of a stretch of
tomlin going from db's coach in tampa
when i met him to one year as the
coordinator in minnesota
to
the pittsburgh steelers the notre dame
of the nfl if you will the pittsburgh
steelers saying this is the guy
and not only does it offer stability in
the short term with regard to potential
playoff
uh appearance as well as recruiting
i think they might have gotten a star i
hate the way brian kelly did it
i hate the timing i don't i don't i
don't hate that he got his money i mean
sorry probably my language give me a
hundred million dollars on bouncing too
you know what i mean i get it but the
timing of it rubbed me the wrong way but
i think it was a blessing in disguise
and
just from the outside looking in it
looks like notre dame
may have actually come up because kelly
rebuilt the program
provided an infrastructure
that a star like brian assuming like
marcus freeman
has an opportunity to build upon so i
wouldn't be surprised
if not only does he continue notre
dame's recent run of success
but actually with his recruiting prowess
puts it over the top and delivers a
national championship sooner than the
guy that's got to go through saban in
the fcc west well jack swarbrick the a.d
in notre dame said that the program is
in much better shape than it was when
brian kelly arrived no question and and
and and
i i will just give a uh
you know pull on the strand that you
threw out there about kelly and and the
timing of it
i i you can't blame him for the timing
of it either because the way that
everything is set up
by the ncaa and school presidents have
to sign off on it and and school
administrators and athletic directors
are clearly signing off on it
is with this early signing period being
in the middle of this month and so much
being put on recruiting and it's being
the lifeblood of the support obviously
you have to make a decision about you
know who you're firing as coaches and
hiring as coaches now and i think it's
totally um
naive to think that kelly hasn't had a
feeler out from lsu
and and and riley a feeler out from usc
uh you know
probably probably probably well before
halloween even you know 100
i mean ufc's job's been vegan since week
two or on has been done for weeks
i listen
you can blame brian kelly
and more than one thing can be true at
the same time
so let's just get a few obvious things
out of the ways just so i'm clear
hey man get your money
yeah i would never begrudge anybody for
getting money
um second thing is this is what brian
kelly does
so
it's like in a relationship
if you if you cheat with someone if you
cheat with somebody who's in a
relationship don't be shocked when they
cheat on you
okay like that's how you got him in the
first place so this is how he this is
how he rolls but here's why i said two
more things one thing to be true at the
same time and you can blame him you just
hit it he's known about lsu since before
saturday or sunday he's known about that
and the recruiting
clock or recruiting calendar only
matters if you're going to another job
which again is his prerogative to take
this is unprecedented for somebody to
leave
when your team
is in contention for a championship if
it was a sunflower seed bowl we've seen
that before
but your team is in contention for a
championship
and you're leaving now
that's
that's uncomfortable and that's putting
it kindly
you know if the object of the exercise
is to compete for championships maybe
lsu does give you a better chance of
competing albeit in the sec west
competing year in and year out for
championships hence your poll question
maybe it does but in 2021
you your players the guys that you
recruited once upon a time to come to
notre dame to win a championship
have an opportunity to do that
so it's the time the timing sucks is it
his fault did he set the calendar no
it did he is his did he do all he could
is is the work done at notre dame
sure but the job wasn't finished but i
mean
of course and and then you know
um it's just a bad look
and it's also uh a dreadful
way to
leave
um
you know adolescents who are they still
are i know they're grown men in terms of
you know their physical prowess but i
mean by the way you say it again
who seem to be taking it better than me
like i may be i have no tithe in notre
dame i don't play for them i didn't go
there and the family members went there
or oklahoma so so so what about this
right what about this how about
we push back this recruiting period i
don't know how far it needs to be in
order to remove this from the equation
is it is it you know the week after the
national championship game you know is
that what it can possibly be and and and
or if you do
hire a coach before this early
recruiting period from another member
school you lose scholarships like there
should be some sort of yeah
of
teeth here
right or you know that look hey look at
each other and just say this is ugly for
notre dame it's not pretty for lsu
either although they're sitting pretty
and the same thing with usc like bye-bye
whatever
they don't care they they already have
one of the you know the top recruits
that lincoln riley had coming to
oklahoma come to them i see all the usc
trojan friends and fans right around
here they're
they're not crying a river at all
they're all fired up and of course
oklahoma fans are like good luck with
the guy who couldn't get out of the
national championship semi-final more
often than not you know and
it's just it's kind of ugly you know so
in essence this kind of is what it is
like it's a dirty world but it's still
spinning can't do nothing about it but
try to live in it but like
you know i would like to see again maybe
it's unrealistic and maybe it's too
complicated to pull off but
you know in the nfl you can't hire a
coach away from a team that's in the
super bowl you know i mean you could
interview them
but they still have to finish the job
you know they can't take the job can
they you know so there are there are
regulations about when you can interview
coaches and when you can hire coaches in
the nfl i mean i guess and for me look i
get that the players are getting you
know the crumbs uh that that are name
image and likeness and a transfer portal
at long last
you know hey you want to make some money
go do extra work you know in order to
make the money that we won't give you um
or make some of the money that we won't
give you
this this entire situation and lincoln
riley i'm okay with i'm okay with
lincoln o'reilly you know
even though you know he pulled in aaron
rodgers and like i'm not gonna be the
coach at lsu
you know i ain't saying nothing about
usc you know and
but i understand that because his team
wasn't going to the playoff for me it's
that these kids and you know the young
men and they know what it is and it's a
business for everybody i get i get it
but nonetheless these guys come in and
are recruited to try to compete for a
championship
and for you to bail on them
albeit for a once in a lifetime
opportunity
is unfair to the very people who
continue to get the shortening to stick
throughout the history of this glorious
sport that's the players are you saying
that uh lincoln riley said he was
inoculated from going to lsu is that
what your reference was right there
yeah that's a great way of saying it
actually yes
he answered the question well he didn't
answer the question but
he wasn't he wasn't president well i
mean he he cut off the question to say
let me just tell you this i will not be
the coach of lsu which is college media
relations 101.
in the nfl fully aware that my attorney
is talking to usc right now talking
about private jets and the
the sale of my two homes the one that i
have
like that just came around in two
seconds right like we didn't see that
one coming yeah that deal came together
quickly but ultimately i think i think
notre dame will win out though and it's
a blessing in disguise i mean i think
you know brian kelly good luck he did
his job there he built to rebuild the
program but
they got a good one by all accounts
in freeman they seem excited about it
and uh you know 35 years old
rising star maybe this is the beginning
of a
of an incredible career that just needed
an opportunity in the form of somebody
else moving on what's on your uh rundown
for later on today at three eastern time
on brother from another uh freeman the
uh defending champs
uh rolling in the nba okay um you know
lamelo ball who's sealing his roof y'all
talking about the cowboys before i came
on okay
i'm just i'm looking forward to watching
micah parsons tonight i don't remember
i don't remember
and i watched a lot of football rich as
a view who's the last guy
to be
that good off the ball on first and
second down and that good off the edge
on third down like that's a package i
don't want to go so far and say it's
unprecedented because
i could be forgetting somebody i would
hate to do that
but usually you got to be good at one or
the other
some guys have been able to do both you
know
it's not unprecedented to be versatile
but he's among the best pass rushers in
the nfl
and he's off the ball linebacker on
first and second down
i yeah i'm trying to think i'm trying to
think because not many pass rushers
are are asked to do coverage as you've
pointed out like that
um
you've asked me that question i'm just
going to my head von miller
you know uh but he didn't really drop
very much um i i don't know i mean
parsons when the when the cowboys
drafted him i don't know if they really
thought or had that defense like
whenever whenever you draft a linebacker
like parsons when you're like the
steelers you're like oh that guy's gonna
rush the passer right right when the
cowboys draft him you're not thinking
that certainly when they got tank
lawrence randy gregory and that's that's
why i keep saying that cowboys are fine
you know the cowboys have all of these
division games left and the division
games that they've played are are easily
their easiest ones on the schedule
certainly since they went one and three
in the afc west and then they barely
beat the patriots in their one other
game against an afc team
right and and so i and and they're gonna
get healthier and to me pollard's the
better running back right now and he's
the one that i think is going to get the
package tonight and despite what uh
jerry jones said and i think we're going
to see that this evening against the
saints
it does feel like uh
something of a confirmation bias for
some people when it comes to dallas like
if you
believe that you know the cowboys know
cowboy and this is this is what they do
they collapse they break your hearts and
the other blah blah blah that's your
brand if that's just how you view dallas
then you know the last few weeks
circumstances aside certainly fed into
that and you know but it's like i'm with
you like
get your jokes off now because i don't
i know that the schedule is all there
for the football team and you know the
eagles
at least before last week felt like they
had a chance to make a run and maybe
they can you know do so i don't think
it's particularly close in that division
um if if the cowboys their full strength
and getting demarcus lawrence back
watching those two dudes come off the
edge tonight is going to be
fascinating to say the least so we'll
get into that and then this major league
baseball lockout yep you know we'll
we'll try not to bore our audience no i
know i i've played relations i'm gonna
have jeff pass in a vspn on later i made
the decision jeff is one of my favorites
and i made the decision because i i lost
all of my remaining here uh during the
2011 lockout uh covering that for nfl
total access and nfl network on a daily
basis it is not fun it's not fun for
fans to hear or listen to i care that's
what i figured i'm just going to have
him on to talk about the beats of why
this has happened and you know there's
going to be a there's a drop dead date
in the minds of both
sets of negotiators right now
and and that's probably a two weeks
before pitchers and catchers report and
then if you push into that that means
you're gonna end up pushing spring
training or you're gonna collapse spring
training in order to get to uh your
first game in april and then suddenly
you're talking about the season not
being as good it's not played under the
same circumstances and and then that's
when fans begin to check out so i want
to know when that drop date is and you
know oh that's that's what i'm going to
have him on later on no let me know what
he said i i think well interestingly
so this first workstoppers in 26 years
um
i don't believe check me on this i don't
believe that
any games have ever been lost to
lockouts
games have been lost strikes but not
lockout i'm not aware of that but to me
it doesn't i think to fans as you know
it doesn't really matter no my point is
i'm with you that
they're going to get this figured out
it's hard to identify middle ground my
point is i i'm optimistic right that
they don't miss
games
in the meantime i'm going to have fun
just watching them be petty because the
first labor uh short labor work stop
excuse me in major league baseball in
the internet era so i'm just look i'm
just enjoying them basically changing
their relationship status and you know
players changing their profile pictures
and the team and they're scrubbing their
digital presence basically just saying
hey we're not on speaking terms right
now so it's kind of fun to watch them be
petty in the meantime michael smith have
a great show tonight really appreciate
our chats we'll do it again thanks again
you guys it's michael smith he and
michael holly on brother from another on
nbc sports on peacock right after this
show at 3 eastern time hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here